oh wang bud don't do this to me
don't do it hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's what i eat in a day review is
sponsored by buildbar
and we will be looking at another
harper's bazaar food diaries video
from got7 boy band member jackson wang
but before i get into it i want to chat
about my sponsor
buildbar you guys know by now that i'm a
fan of these bars they're
honestly one of the only protein bars
that i've ever tried and
actually liked because they don't taste
like chalk
they actually taste like a fluffy
marshmallow
nougat chocolate bar but with protein
so today's flavor is gonna be
it's gonna be may peanut butter
yeah love peanut butter this one's got
19 grams of protein
let's have a little tasty like a peanut
butter
cup so this is awesome just for helping
to boost up the protein in a meal or
snack
and because it is a lower sugar bar i
would pair this with a piece of fruit or
toast
if i was going to eat it as like a
post-workout snack
definitely breastfeeding mama appetite
approved anyways the flavors i've tried
so far are all really super yummy and
i'm so excited
to make my way through the rest of them
with you guys so if you want to try them
out yourself
i will leave a link below for 20 off of
your order
and you can use my promo code abby sharp
20. also you can pause the screen or
look in my description to check out my
disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating
a reminder that this format follows a
celebrity's description of
what they eat and tells me very little
about its accuracy
portions brands cooking preparation etc
not to mention their overall
relationship with food so definitely
take this more as general education to
the masses
not as specific recommendations to
jackson
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to this channel and ring that little
bell so that you never miss out on a
episode all right let's eat hey this is
jackson we're from china and this
is everything i eat every single day oh
god not
another kelly ripa situation wang don't
do this to me
i am all about variety folks and i am
just going to have to pray
that he didn't actually mean that he
eats only these foods
every single day they better be
really damn delicious foods let's take a
look
to make my detox shake
in the blender grapes strawberry
cabbage orange apple sometimes
pear and i put honey and ice and water
in the blender
and then i look at the river to meditate
myself just to calm down
because my my morning needs to be calm
this interview is already feeling
the opposite of calm to me as we kick
off with the most intense description of
a smoothie
that i have ever bared witness to uh
sorry i mean my bad
jackson affectionately calls this
concoction his
detox shake first of all folks
regular subbies know exactly what i'm
about to say here but i'm going to
repeat it again for some of jackson's
friends who
might be new here on abby's kitchen you
do not need to detox
you don't need to cleanse your body
actually has all the
fabulous organs that it needs to do the
job for you
all day everyday moving along
more importantly i need to know does
that cabbage
not make the smoothie taste like farts i
mean i love cabbage
i love cabbage it's literally one of my
favorite vegetables of
all time but i feel like putting it in
the vitamix first thing in the morning
would have some kind of
tear gas napalm effect
i don't know please please please let me
know if i'm unnecessarily concerned
about the fart shake
let me know in the comments below but
rank shake aside there's
absolutely nothing wrong with this drink
here i mean all super healthy
ingredients with
lots of colorful fruits and veg so
for sure we are getting a nice dose of
micronutrients and fiber as well
but but i would love to see
a little protein or some healthy fats in
this meal to help bump up the satiety
factor
especially because we know research
suggests that drinking your calories
is just never going to be as physically
or emotionally satisfying
as chewing them so throwing in some
greek yogurt
silken tofu nut butter protein powder
flax hemp hearts
or soy milk would definitely give this
breakfast
a little legs let's see what's next am i
a coffee drinker or
tea drinker it depends on the day if
that day i have
work i will drink coffee after my meal
ice americano because it helps me to
not be as swollen in front of the camera
you mean
it makes you i mean i have never heard
of anyone using
coffee to reduce swelling
but coffee is a laxative and a diuretic
so jackson
might be describing a desire to use
coffee to i don't know
reduce stomach distension caused from
constipation
or lack of motility but i want to see
some more food
if i'm outside if i'm traveling around i
don't have the blender with me
i'll take two salads just to
get my vitamins and greens for the day
i mean i am all about getting in your
greens and i appreciate his dedication
to
getting those nutrients in but making a
meal
out of not one but two basic vegetable
salads is
just not enough especially if this is in
combination with his morning
detox shake now even if there wasn't a
detox shake in his day
one salad would be enough and i would
want to see that
beefed up with some protein like chicken
tofu beans eggs or fish
some kind of slow digesting carb like
roasted sweet potatoes
quinoa rice pasta or bread
and definitely would want to see some
fats in there
through nuts oil avocado or olives
especially because jackson says that
this meal is happening
right after a trip to the gym when we
really need that protein
and carb to help us recover also getting
some fat in there is particularly
important since
jackson seems genuinely concerned about
getting in his micronutrients
and a lot of the nutrients found in
these salads depend on
fat to maximize absorption for somebody
who clearly is so
short on time making those salads
more nutrient and calorie dense would
not only
be more nutritious but also would just
be a more
efficient way of eating let's see what
he's having for snacks
snacks of the day i love bananas
or i love sweets sometimes
but not a lot okay bananas are great
snacks
but in the context of this diet
probably wouldn't be my first choice
probably wouldn't be my
10th choice i mean honestly there's
already a ton of produce going on here
and
not much else and sweets i think there's
totally room for candy in the context of
a healthy diet which
obviously this guy has a lot of
micronutrients in his day
but let's think about what we can add to
this rather than take away
we want to try to limit the naked carbs
in our diet
but it doesn't mean that we need to omit
higher sugar foods completely
so we could pair that banana with some
nut butter or the candy could complement
some seeds nuts yogurt or cheese
that would make a more satisfying and
balanced snack
what's a weekend cheat meal lunch uh
burgers uh pizza
burgers i try to take the top of the the
bread out
because i feel better so some classic
cheat meal suspects and you know how i
feel about that term
but man if he's taken the bread off the
burger for his cheat meal
what the [ __ ] is he eating on a normal
day
probably not a whole lot as we can see
what's the
ingredient of food that i definitely
avoid carbs carbs and spicy like
carbs i don't take it because i know
like i can't but spicy i
my body doesn't allow me to take it i'm
i don't know i think i'm kind of
allergic to it so
first of all based on his food recall so
far
it doesn't look like he avoids carbs as
a whole
he is eating a lot of fruit but it does
sound like he tries to avoid
refined carbohydrates like bread that
are often painted by society as
bad now i appreciate that there may be
other components to these kinds of foods
that
don't feel good to him like gluten or
wheat
and that's fair but i think a lot of
people unnecessarily
demonize carbs like grains and then
praise carbs like fruit
and that just doesn't make sense to me
for example one medium banana has around
100 calories
with three grams of fiber and a gram of
protein in contrast
one slice of good quality whole grain
bread has the same amount of calories
but with up to five grams each of fiber
and protein
so i'm not poo pooing fruit like i love
fruit fruit is so important there's so
many amazing nutrients in fruit
but i'm just telling people that
grain-based carbs
are also not inherently bad or unhealthy
they just offer a different variety of
really good nutrients
as for the spicy comment it is possible
to be allergic to spices
it occurs in about two percent of the
population
and the most problematic spices for
allergy sufferers are
celery garlic cinnamon sesame turmeric
onion and mustard but i think what
jackson is referring to
probably is more a sensitivity to heat
rather than an actual allergy which is
the body's
immune response a lot of people find
that spicy food
gives them the run what is actually
happening is that the spicy compound in
chiles capsaicin
binds the receptor that regulates body
temperature
called the trpv1
and that causes your gi system to cramp
up
become stimulated and move things along
the result is a sudden urge to of course
use the washroom and if you've ever felt
like your anus is on fire after a good
curry or burrito
it's because there are trpv1 receptors
up in your as well so if it burns going
in
it's probably going to burn going out so
if you're struggling with spicy
choose a lower fat higher fiber meal to
pair with your spice since
excess fat can actually increase bile
salts which irritates the skin
around your bum well boy that escalated
quickly
anyways let's see what this kid is
having for dinner
what's a typical dinner for me uh
meat and yeah any kind of meat
white wine uh cloudy bay
meat and white wine that's literally a
fad diet from the 1960s i mean i guess
i'm glad to hear about some protein and
some fat in his day finally
but we could balance this out a bit
again
with a source of complex carbs and we
could shift that second salad from lunch
down here to make it more of a complete
meal
because no despite what i sometimes try
to tell myself
wine is not a side dish now of course if
you were to occasionally have a lot of
veggies
in the first half of your day then no of
course you could go easier on the
veggies at dinner
every meal doesn't need to be a
perfectly curated
sectioned off food guide informed plate
but i would say that
if this became your daily routine which
it sounds like it is for jackson we
could achieve
more stable energy levels throughout the
day
by spreading out our carb and protein
intake
over the day late night snacking a glass
of
honey water honey water 2021's
lemon water now for someone who
allegedly limits carbs
there is actually a lot of carbs like
everything except for the steak
is carbs do you cook do i
cook um
no he looks so concerned there
poor kid wow okay well
that was an unusually uncomfortable
interview to watch
not gonna lie but what can i say about
mr wang here first of all there's just
not a lot of calories going on here to
sustain
such a busy rehearsal shooting and
performance
schedule like i feel a little sluggish
just listening to him talk so i can see
now
why the honey water and coffee are such
an integral part
of his day but food like actual food
would be my first recommendation for
actual energy
just fyi now he could be eating a 16
ounce porterhouse steak for all i know
so my bigger concern beyond just
calories is
balance it seems like each meal is kind
of a
mono meal with huge amounts of fruit in
a smoothie
huge amounts of vegetables in his lunch
and just
straight up meat at his dinner now i get
that the kid is busy and it sounds
like it is hard for him to even fit
these meals in
but man like we could throw some canned
chickpeas or nuts onto that salad
like add some yogurt or nut butter to
the smoothie
and serve that steak with a little
grilled asparagus and just like a simple
potato
to make it a more saturating whole meal
so it's not about taking foods away not
even the candy that he said he has
so not much of it just a little bit
it's about finding little ways to make
those meals
more balanced and your energy levels
more stabled
all day long and that my friends is all
i have for you today
thank you again to buildbar for
sponsoring if you like this video please
give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye